au coup d'envoi les templiers devait
prouver que la défaite contre les
vikings n'était qu'une erreur de
parcours les élans courtois sont donc
rentrer rapidement dans la partie face
aux gladiateurs de la queue-en-brie avec
deux touchdowns inscrire davantage que
les templiers ont dû gérer tout au long
de la partie
c'est juste qu'on est c'est un rythme
différent voilà on s'est peut-être un
peu reposé enfin endormir vous a laissé
endormir par l'autre équipe je veux dire
mais mais voilà on a quand même su
réagir et et garder le score pendant les
templiers l'emportent finalement sur le
score de 20 à 14
c'était une belle équipe en face qui
nous a posé quelques problèmes
on aurait pu se mettre à l'abri beaucoup
plus rapidement mais en face à une belle
équipe et maintenant ça à nous deux ça
nous d'élever le niveau maintenant avec
cette victoire les templiers d'elancourt
est leader de la conférence lors de
deuxième division avec quatre victoires
en cinq matches disputés
des résultats qui permettent d'espérer
des playoffs en fin de saison une
possible montée en première division
on est là pour gagner tous les matches
et si on gagne tous les matches on est
champion la fin de l'année donc le même
objectif c'est toujours la même chose on
est là pour gagner le prochain match on
va le gagner aussi on va travailler en
inventant de pour bien bosser et savez
faire
prochain match pour les templiers le
samedi 30 mars à domicile contre les
dragons de paris
[Musique]